bonjour à toutes et tous la saison 2 de
Loki a été magistrale et le final l'a
été encore plus sur tous les plans la
série loky a été grande et Marvel a
réussi à nous proposer quelque chose de
mémorable la hype est clairement revenu
et justement j'ai envie de vous reparler
de ce final encore une fois car bien que
la fin de Loki saison 2 nous apporte une
véritable conclusion pour son héros et
de nombreuses réponses concernant tout
ce qui a été introduit depuis début et
bien il n'en reste pas moins de nombreux
mystères qui dit fin d'une question dit
l'apport d'une nouvelle et nombreux sont
les détails et les nonit qui nous
laissent dans le doute il faut
aujourd'hui que nous revenions et que
nous parlions de celui qui demeure et du
défi que Loki a
engagé mais avant ça grâce à l'action de
Loki de maintenir les branches du
multivers en vie je peux vous donner à
partir de maintenant un moyen d'accéder
au contenu disponible dans les autres
réalités c'est Nord VPN grâce à Nord VPN
vous pouvez depuis chez vous ou
n'importe quel endroit changer votre
localisation pour accéder au films et
séries encore indisponible en France
c'est le meilleur moyen par exemple de
voir ou revoir htman quantumania les
gardiens de la galaxie volume 3 ou the
marvels prochainement tout ça en un clic
de manière sécurisée et sur une totalité
de six appareils différents mais cela ne
s'arrête pas là car Nord VPN vous
propose une offre inédite seulement du
29 novembre jusqu'au 9 janvier si vous
habitez en France ou en Belgique vous
pourrez profiter d'une remise
exceptionnelle sur les abonnements de 2
ans ajoutter à cela vous aurez également
4 mois offerts sur l'abonnement et la
serie sur le gâteau vous recevrez une
carte Amazon de 10 20 ou 30 € selon
l'abonnement de 2 ans choisi de quoi en
faire profiter la famille du coup et
préparer les cadeaux de Noël c'est une
offre exclusive et limitée du 29
novembre jusqu'au 9 janvier je le
rappelle donc si vous êtes intéressé
n'hésitez pas à accéder au lien
disponible en description je remercie
Nord VPN d'avoir sponsorisé la vidéo
recentrons-nous à partir de maintenant
sur l'épisode final de la série
Loki pour vous remettre dans le bain la
série Loki est née à partir d'un
événement Nexus lorsque dans Avengers
game nos chers héros ont voulu ramener
le téceracte de l'année 2012 dans le
présent ce dernier a fini dans les mains
de Loki qui s'en est servi pour s'enfuir
ce moment n'était pas prévu l'histoire
que nous connaissons a été changée et
cela a donné naissance à une nouvelle
branche dans le multivers une branche où
Loki s'est enfui avec le téceracte bien
évidemment désigné comme une erreur par
le TVA ces derniers ont arrêté loky et
élagué la branche fraîchement apparue
pour éviter la naissance d'autres
nouvelles branches mais en réalité tout
était
prévu Loki est une cible un but une
raison pour le directeur du TVA celui
qui demeure est à la recherche d'un
successeur capable de poursuivre son
œuvre et le dieu de la malice est le
candidat idéal à ses yeux en fait cela
soulève un point qui mérite d'être
argumenté c'est pourquoi celui qui
demeure souhaite partir ce sujet est une
véritable interprétation pour le moment
et personnellement je vois les choses
ainsi celui qui demeure est un acteur de
la guerre multiverselle et cette guerre
il nous l'a rappelé à de maintes
reprises c'est une guerre brutal où rien
ne survit dans le multivers tout n'est
que destruction tout n'est qu'atrocité
et mort la question est donc la suivante
comment et quoi sauver dans cette
annihilation totale en tant qu'expert du
voyage dans le temps et du multivers il
a donc isolé le flux temporel sacré cré
le TVA le dogme des ekeepers après une
infinité de tentatives pour améliorer
l'histoire sans
succès celui qui demeure a fait les
choix douloureux et s placé en solitude
totale à la fin des temps pour préserver
et veiller sur le peu qu'il a réussi à
sauver de la guerre multiversel et ce
pendant une durée incalculable et il est
bien là le problème après avoir vécu une
éternité tout seul sur son trône
solitaire est-ce que l'on n pas envie de
passer à autre chose est-ce que l'on a
pas envie de partir bien sûr mais étant
désormais au sein de problématique qui
le dépasse complètement ce qui compte
c'est que ce qui a été sauvé ce qui a
été bâti se poursuive après et cela
limitera la souffrance et les
destructions si on se tourne vers les
comics le cas de celui qui demeure
rappelle véritablement la fin de vie
d'imortus le maître des limbes est la
dernière incarnation de Kang le
conquérant et sa personne ainsi que son
rôle sont uniques dans le multivers
imortus est le prime Kong l'identité
ultime qui a surpassé ses autres
lui-même un être qui a délaissé les
conquête et les voyages pour se
concentrer sur l'immortalité et le temps
Immortus est la forme la plus sage et la
plus expérimentée de Kang le Conquérant
son existence après avoir vécu ses
autres identités a été de surveiller que
le temps se déroule correctement que son
luit du passé empreunte le même chemin
et il a cherchait à démêler les conflits
temporels créés par les variants de Kang
mais à un moment donné imortus alors
très âgé et qui a désormais pu vivre son
véritable amour avec ravona sans que sa
fin est pre il souhaite être enfin
libéré de la prison du temps et partir
définitivement accompagné de son amour
néanmoins comment immortu et ravona
vont-ils mourir et bien le maître du
temps a tout organisé à l'aide de son
fils adoptif Marcus Immortus le seigneur
des limbes va convoquer six versions de
ravona jeune et l'une d'entre elles
devra mettre fin à la vie d'imortus et
de sa bien-aimée ravona et pourquoi
a-t-il fait ça et bien pr premièrement
Immortus et ravona seront enfin libérés
et pourront se reposer éternellement
mais également cela va permettre de
faire passer un message à ravona et la
faire évoluer celle qui va mettre fin à
la vie d'imortus et sa compagne c'est la
ravona originelle et la rendre témoin de
l'amour entreimortus et ravona âgé c'est
pour l'inspiré elle qui est actuellement
en plein doute de sa relation avec Kang
et de son rôle au sein de son
même dans la mort imortus a essayé
d'orienter le destin et influencer
l'histoire après avoir finalement trouvé
le digne Loki qui pourrait devenir son
successeur grâce à la route tracée lui
permettant d'évoluer et de prendre
conscience il ne reste plus qu'une
étape
après sa mort il fallait pour celui qui
demeure que loky expérimente et
comprenne par lui-même que la seule
solution c'est la survie du flux
temporel sacré l'épisode 6 est le début
et la fin de la boucle malgré sa
disparition tout a été façonné pour que
Loki soit dans le bon mindset pour
terminer la quête he remains a permis à
Loki d'accéder à l'érrance temporelle il
a orienter ravona à trouver Victor
timely pour permettre à Loki et ses
compagnons d'accéder au cœur temporel et
l'expérimenté sous toutes les coutures
alors qu'au final tout était truqué le
cœur temporel est une sécurité la
protection ultime du flux temporel sacré
il permet simplement à ce dernier
d'exister et si nous choisissons de ne
plus élaguer les branches et bien nous
retournons au point de départ mais sans
le TVA qui sera reconstruit derrière
soit sinon tout meurt les branches
n'arrivent pas à survivre sans le cœur
temporel qui de toute façon est façonné
dans tous les cas pour les détruire
lorsque la surchauffe arrive et si tant
bien que mal le multiver et les branches
arrivent à survivre nous arrivons à la
dernière option et celle qui a toujours
été désignée comme la pire la guerre
multiverselle où rien ne survit pas même
le flux temporel sacré et toute cette
manipulation va encore plus loin celui
qui demeure après avoir guidé manipulé
et H Orient loky vers le mindset désiré
par le directeur du TVA il va le coincer
et l'obliger à faire le fameux choix
difficile c'est le moment clé de toute
l'histoire bien qu'il a désigné Sylvie
et Loki comme ses véritable successeurs
sylvie est en réalité un instrument le
véritable concerné
celui qui demeure a permis à Ly et Syvie
de se rencontrer pour que leur liaison
définisse le pivot de l'avenir il n'y a
pas plus déchirant et destructeur que de
faire un choix difficile lié à l'amour
Sylvie n'a connu qu'une vie de
désolation et de fuite à cause du TVA on
sait même pas la raison de son
Nexus
sylvie a été meurtrie tout le long de sa
vie dans le but qu'elle devienne une
révolutionnaire du TVA une figure
assoifffée de revanche qui n'entendra
jamais
raison la route qui lui a été tracée
c'est pour qu'elle soit omnubilée par sa
revanche et qu'elle tue celui qui
demeure il n'y a pas d'autre issu
possible et c'est justement pour que
Loki fasse le choix de la tuer Loki doit
tuer Sylvie sinon tout le monde meurt
Loki doit tuer Sylvie et le TVA pourra
vivre Loki doit tuer Sylvie et cela le
changera à tout jamais c'est la fin de
l'amour il obtient le trône gouverne le
flux temporel sacré avec celui qui
demeure le temps de véritablement
devenir comme ce que le directeur a
prévu avant de prendre sa
place
et cette route pavée par celui qui
demeure nous fait un beau parallèle où
ce dernier a fait le choix de délaisser
ravona pour le flux
temporel cependant comme vous le savez
Loki ne va pas faire ce choix face au
choix imposé par celui qui demeure le
résultat semble quelque peu inattendu
Loki souhaite briser le cœur temporel et
changer l'issue du scénario et donc
permettre à la fois aux branches
d'exister garder Sylvie en vie et en
même temps préserver ses amis dans le
TVA contre toute attente la guerre
multiverselle qui nous a toujours été
présentée comme la pire option possible
celle où il est possible que tout soit
détruit et que plus rien nexiste devient
la porte de sortie car elle est la seule
permettant d'accéder à l'espoir
d'atteindre le vérit libre
arbitre celui qui demeure qui jusque
maintenant avait le contrôle assis bien
confortablement dans son siège se lève
pour confronter Loki en face à face et
éveiller la véritable prise de
conscience qu'il doit vivre on ne doit
pas aller vers la guerre multiverselle
le cœur temporel et le flux temporel
sacré sont la seule option
possible malgré le silence de
celui qui demeure argumentera le plus
possible pour que Loki n'aille pas dans
cette direction et
pourtant nous retournons de nouveau à la
même issue que l'épisode 6 de la saison
1 succession ou guerre multiverselle et
plus que ça encore nous retournons une
fois de plus dans une boucle mais une
boucle bien plus grande avec le choix
difficile et effectué par Loki il va
falloir repasser par une nouvelle guerre
multiverselle et là du coup qu'est-ce
qu'il se passe exactement avec celui qui
demeure comment doit se dérouler
l'avenir l'après Loki saison 2 déjà ce
qui est sûr c'est que celui qui demeure
n'est plus sa manipulation s'est en
quelque sorte retourné contre lui tout
comme Immortus il voulait partir
néanmoins il devait préparer l'après de
sa disp disarition comme il nous l'a
affirmé dans la saison 1 après le seuil
il ne sait plus comment la suite va se
dérouler le futur n'est que probabilité
et c'est important de le garder en tête
c'est un concept que l'on retrouve même
dans les comics d'ailleurs avant le
seuil celui qui demeure maîtrisait
absolument tout mais après il a mis en
place son plan où Sylvie Le tuit pour
que Loki effectue la boucle de la saison
2 pour qu'il s'éveille sur la situation
avant de retourner avant la mort de he
who remains et décide de l'accompagner
avant de le succéder sauf qu'à cause de
l'accès à l'érance temporelle Loki a
désormais les pleins pouvoirs et il peut
voyager n'importe où et n'importe quand
par conséquent en choisissant de ne pas
suivre ce qu'imposait celui qui demeure
Loki retourne au moment de la fusion
temporelle causée par le cœur soit
l'épisode 4 et à ce moment-là bah celui
qui demeure n'est plus ce n'est qu'un
cadavre en décomposition si vous vous
souvenez bien donc le directeur du TVA
dans l'image c'est'est autopiégé
d'ailleurs l'ascension de Loki nous
démontre bien qu'à la fin des temps tout
ce qu'avait bâti celui qui demeure s'
frrite et disparaît c'est comme si son
nom avait été effacé de
l'histoire comme je vous ai dit le futur
n'est que probabilité et c'est ça la
faiblesse de celui qui dem Meur il était
convaincu que Loki éviterait la guerre
multiverselle et ferait donc le choix de
gouverner avec lui après tout il reste
un variant de kangle conquérant il est
un personnage unul lui-même et qui ne
supporte pas ses autres lui-mêm cela
démontre par ailleurs pourquoi il n'a
jamais fait en sorte de former un
variant de lui-même pour prendre sa
place et tracer sa route les kanges sont
par définition tourner autour d'eux-même
ils veulent être supérieurs regardez
comment celui qui demeure change de ton
et devient méprisant à l'écart de Victor
timely un Variant qu'il a manipulé pour
servir la grande machination afin de
faire évoluer Loki il sait que
contrairement à ses variants Loki est
désormais conscient du multivers il est
beaucoup plus tourné dans l'altruisme
néanmoins il ne s'attendait pas à ce que
Loki le soit autant au point carrément
de se sacrifier et à partir de
maintenant il faut voir comment Marvel
va adapter la suite en fait celui qui
demeure est éit le prime Kang le Kang
principal qui a surpassé tous les autres
et qui était destiné à devenir le seul
et le
[Musique]
véritable comme nous l'avons vu lors de
sa présentation il y a de fortes chances
que celui qui demeure tout comme le
prime Kang des comics soit l'entité qui
a traversé plusieurs identités avant de
devenir le directeur du TVA le nom
souverain traduit sa période en tant que
ramatoute le Conquérant vous le savez
tous c'est Kang puis celui qui demeure
c'est un peu l'équivalent d' morortus
dans les comics néanmoins ce qui fait
que le prime Kong est justement le prime
Kong et bien c'est parce qu'il est guidé
secrètement par son luit du futur
Immortus et elle est là la véritable
problématique en fait dans les comics le
primemkang est victime d'un destin qu'il
n'a pas choisi il est la marionnette
d'immortus qui lui-même agit au nom des
timeekeepers et qui cherche à ce que
tout déroule comme prévu dans le temps
sauf qu'à cause ou grâce à une
divergence à la fin des temps et bien
qu'Angle conquérant va finalement
prendre conscience des plans d'imortus
et il va se rebeller ce qui va donner
naissance à certainement le point clé le
plus important de l'histoire du
conquérant la guerre du destin Kang va
confronter Immortus et les ekeepers et à
l'issue du combat ce dernier sera enfin
libéré Kang et imortus qui sont sont la
même personne mais à des moments
différents du temps deviendront chacun
des identités à part entière libérant
donc qu'Angle conquérant de l'obligation
de devenir Immortus quand je relativise
j'ai parfois un peu l'impression que
c'est ce que nous avons vécu dans la
série Loki dans le sens où celui qui
demeure a tracé le destin des gens il a
façonné l'histoire et l'empêche de
prendre une tournure qui pourrait amener
le chaos Loki du coup dans la symbolique
prend le rôle du conquérant car son
destin a été manipulé et guidé par celui
qui demeure pour prendre sa place et
donc dans l'image devenir comme lui sauf
qu'il a brisé tout ça il n'y a plus
question de destin le futur n'est
désormais que probabilité nous nous
tournons désormais vers le libre arbitre
la question du destin est libérée et
Loki vient de donner une nouvelle chance
pour qu'on sorte du cycle et bâtir
quelque chose de meilleur par conséquent
cela amène une c certaine réponse par
rapport à la future guerre multiverselle
à venir celui qui demeure devient celui
qui demeure parce qu'il a été forgé par
les événements qu'il a vécu et non car
il est né pour devenir celui qui demeure
en fait celui qui demeure n'est qu'un
variant de kangle conquérant parmi tant
d'autres à la base mais il est devenu le
prime Kang parce qu'il est celui qui a
pris la route lui permettant de le
devenir et par la suite après la guerre
multiverselle il pourra s'ériger en tant
que celui qui demeure néanmoins ce n'est
pas obligé du coup que ce soit le même
qui redevienne celui qui demeure tout
n'est que question de probabilité
contrairement au comics celui qui
demeure s'est isolé et a empêché le flux
temporel sacré de se ramifier et ensuite
après le seuil où il ne maîtrisait plus
totalement l'avenir il est finalement
décédé donc il n'y a pas la possibilité
qu'il influence son lui plus jeune à
devenir qui il deviendra ce sera par la
force des choses la guerre multiv univel
a été provoqué à cause des Kang c'est
leur guerre donc naturellement un
d'entre eux doit gagner solutionner le
conflit et finir sur le trône à la fin
car ce sont eux les concernés et les
experts si l'un des Kang suit à peu près
la même route que celle de celui qui
demeure route que ce dernier nous a
partagé dans le final de Loki saison 1
et bien il aura toutes les cartes pour
devenir le nouvel élu qui arrivera à la
fin des temps
après voilà bien évidemment il faut que
nos héros gagnent à la fin donc les
probabilités joueront en leur faveur
contrairement aux comics le futur n'est
désormais plus écrit n'oubliez pas ce
mot probabilité effectivement Kang dans
quantumania a vu comment cela allait se
terminer il a vu la future guerre
multiverser l'avenir mais c'est parce
que la probabilité qu'une guerre se
déclenche est trop forte et c'est ce qui
la rend inévitable les Kang sont biaisés
et celui de quantumania en est la preuve
il a conscience qu'une guerre va arriver
mais au final ses actions traduisent
déjà la guerre à venir ils souhaitent
anhiler des réalités ils souhaitent se
venger de ses compères et ce sont des
actes qui donnent naissance justement à
la fameuse guerre multiverselle bref je
pense qu'il est temps de terminer cette
vidéo je souhaitais à tout prix revenir
sur le cadre de celui qui demeure et
c'est maintenant fait n'oubliez pas que
ce ne sont que mes interprétations et
mon avis à vous de me dire en
commentaire le vôtre et en vrai
sincèrement nous n'avons pas encore tout
dit il y a encore pas mal de mystères
concernant Loki j'aimerais bien par
exemple que l'on parle de Victor timely
car son cas est assez intéressant et
surtout il faut expliquer ce qu'il se
passe pour lui après la saison 2
j'aimerais également vous faire savoir
que le prochain pourquoi sont-ils s
uniqu est en préparation avancé je vous
sors ça au plus vite et allez j'ai envie
de vous le révéler nous allons parler de
Galactus sur ce merci à tous d'avoir
regarder la vidéo n'oubliez pas le petit
pouce bleu et à vous abonner c'était
arargoroc merci ciao tout le
[Musique]
monde